foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday February 10th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
on Sunday the Kansas City Chiefs take on
the Philadelphia Eagles at Super Bowl
57. advertising is usually a big Topic
in the lead-up to the big game and often
when we talk about ads around the Super
Bowl we talk about how expensive they
are Brands spending huge sums to get
their commercials in front of so many
eyeballs but for Twitter it's a little
different this year according to an
email viewed by The Wall Street Journal
the social media platform is offering a
last minute deal to advertisers for the
Super Bowl why is this fire sale
happening and will it attract companies
joining us to discuss this is our
digital advertising reporter patience
Hagen hey patients thanks for joining us
thanks for having me Zoe let's begin
with a bit of background since Elon Musk
took over last year how has advertising
on the platform been doing in general
well after he took over a lot of
advertisers quit the platform he
immediately introduced a bunch of
changes within in days and weeks of
taking over
he completely changed the site's rules
for Content moderation he reinstated a
lot of banned accounts and those actions
made advertisers worried about what kind
of content their ads might appear next
to so Brands pulled so much money out of
Twitter so now they have this Super Bowl
offer though can you tell us what
Twitter is exactly offering what they're
telling potential advertisers they're
basically offering deals on Super Bowl
advertising one email that I saw that
was sent to ad buyers they called it a
fire sale you know they're telling
people this is a bargain and having good
prices to lure them back they sell ads
for Super Bowl weekend and packages and
they offered a package for 250k this
year usually the cheapest package of
those ads starts at 500k Twitter's also
bragging to advertisers about the
popularity of the site these days
they're telling advertisers that the
number of conversations on the site
happening about the Super Bowl and the
NFL is up significantly compared to last
year are advertisers being swayed by
these offers and you know by the claims
that they've got more users on the
platform some advertisers are especially
smaller advertisers are being lured back
by the deals according to what ad
agencies tell me the biggest Spenders
and the people who left with concerns of
our content moderation for the most part
are not really being swayed by this is
Twitter releasing any new tools or any
features that might help advertisers get
over their concerns about content
moderation yes Twitter recently released
a new tool that allows advertisers to
block their ads from appealing next to
tweets that mention certain words this
is a way to avoid vulgar tweets or
inflammatory tweets about certain
controversial topics advertisers can
create a list of 1000 keywords and keep
their ads from appearing above or below
tweets that contain those keywords
that's an offering that has appealed to
some advertisers as for the brands that
are going back a lot of them them are
interested in it and for the brands that
aren't going back my sources tell me a
lot of them are listening with interest
to the idea they're really trying to
keep their finger on the pulse of how
Twitter is working on its content
moderation has Twitter commented at all
about this fire sale or about
advertisers returning at all Twitter has
not commented about those things to the
Wall Street Journal so they have this
big deal for advertisers they're talking
about the number of people commenting
about the Super Bowl on their platform
how important is the Super Bowl or has
the Super Bowl been historically to
Twitter historically it's been their
biggest weekend of the Year Saturday
Sunday and Monday all those three days
together bring in 35 million dollars in
U.S ad revenue and Sunday accounts for
most of that the game day itself
Twitter's really built up a reputation
for itself as the place where people go
to react to cultural events when they're
watching the big game live on TV they're
often like scanning Twitter to see what
other people are saying about it and
they're sharing their instant reaction
to the game into the ads Twitter's built
up that reputation and they've really
milked it kind of a breakthrough moment
for them that made advertisers realize
how they could leverage it came in the
2013 Super Bowl or after the halftime
show there was a blackout for a little
while people took to Twitter to talk
about the blackout and Oreo famously
tweeted a line that said like power's
out no problem you can still dunk in the
dark it was just a catchy thing that
really took on it was a really
successful tweet and that's what made
marketers realize Twitter is the place
to be during the Super Bowl it becomes
the water cooler for the world we have
to be there to be part of the
conversation patients you cover
advertising you know in general how does
Twitter then stack up to other Super
Bowl advertising which we often talk
about as being a huge place for
marketers the Marquee part of the Super
Bowl advertising is the commercials and
the game which this year cost like seven
million dollars for a 30 second spot but
Twitter is like that's the place where
people react to what they're seeing on
TV and that's a place where any brand
can afford to buy at least a little bit
that's a place where you can really
control how you spend you're not going
to be priced out of it so brands of all
kinds usually they would have a strategy
for Twitter to be part of the
conversation whether that's buying ads
on Twitter or even just tweeting
organically completely free it's a
crucial way for them to participate in
the big day I'm curious if this goes
right or this goes wrong for Twitter
what it means for its advertising
Revenue going forward if it goes right
for Twitter this could be like their big
moment to lure Brands back and establish
that they still occupy that crucial part
of the nation conversation that they're
the Town Square for the world like Elon
musk wants it to be
if it doesn't go well you know there's
certainly other social platforms that
want that kind of status Tick Tock for
instance they're becoming a place where
a lot of people go to react to Live
Events and share cultural moments so
there's plenty of other competitors kind
of waiting in the wings to Hoover up
that ad spending and Hoover up the way
that brands use Twitter during huge
cultural events alright that's our
reporter patience Haggin patience thanks
so much for joining us thanks for having
me and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week tnb's producer is Julie Chang
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
sinsley I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
foreign
[Music]